with reaction is the relatable podcast
host ally Beth Stuckey in the host of
America first on the Salem radio network
dr. Sebastian Gorka dr. Gorka you know
firsthand as a world traveler that
socialism when tried has failed
Obama tried he wanted to redistribute
the wealth his policies stifling
regulation high taxes redistribution
thirteen million more Americans and food
stamps eight million more in poverty
doesn't work sure my parents crawled
across a minefield to escape the kind of
system that under cassio Cortez which it
wishes to create in America I think it's
very telling that she has these latent
totalitarian tendencies whereby she
thinks the people's will in Venezuela
should be ignored and medoras regime
should be recognized
can you imagine Sean if in the last six
days the media had paid as much
attention to Venezuela as they did to
the fake news about the Catholic
Covington schoolboys being racists if
they'd actually told the truth about
Venezuela
nobody in America would wish what this
woman wishes to put upon us 40 countries
have tried this system it has all failed
redistribution of wealth means you have
to take it from somebody else first
socialism is inherently dictatorial and
this woman Ocasio Cortez wishes to see
that in America but it's all the
Democrats now it's a Cascio Cortez it is
nice we surrend build dole read de
Blasio Ollie it is you know every
Democrat that wants to and aspires to be
president they want to take us in this
direction the promise that was closest
to nationalized health care was keep you
doctor keep your plan pay less well
people saw their premiums go up as much
as two hundred percent or more millions
lost their doctors millions of Americans
only have one choice in many many towns
and counties in this country
right well it hasn't worked here it
hasn't worked anywhere else and yet we
keep on seeing these recycled ideas from
people like Bernie Sanders and Acacio
Cortez and like you said they used to be
on the fringes we could kind of laugh at
someone like Sanders or laugh at a 29
year old who really knows nothing about
politics but when you see someone like
Nancy Pelosi or a mainstream Democrat
acquiesce to people like her it really
starts to worry you when the majority of
the country seems to be leaning in that
direction
specifically Millennials which is soon
to be the biggest generation ever in our
nation but Nancy Pelosi understands that
she has to acquiesce to the far left
radical open border socialist Democrats
or else Democrats aren't going to stay
in power because people are looking into
people like Acacio Cortez and Bernie
Sanders to be the future of this country
Elizabeth Warren and her the thing is I
guess it's appealing when look everybody
I've spent an early part of my adult
life was independent financially since
I'm 18 the college I went to I paid for
myself I work full-time while doing it
you know live paycheck to paycheck for
many years of my my 20s and it's
appealing maybe to a lot of people
because it would take away their fear
the government is going to provide day
care health care provide housing maybe a
new car will be the next proposal doctor
Gorka but don't worry we're gonna take
it from those people but it's really
about them keeping power it's a power
play and it will always disappoint it's
only appealing if you have no sense of
history and the suffering of millions of
people our hundred million people killed
and hundreds of millions who have been
persecuted that's a reality it's nice in
the kind of way of people giving you
something for nothing which not know but
never actually happens in real life
that's the shame of it
the radicals have taken over the
Democrat Party that's why we have a shot
down Nancy is giving in to the
extremists all right thank you both for
being with us